any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
here we go stephen meyer dr stephen
meyer i am now going to ask you the
questions i ask all my guests
they are metaphysical i know that that
will not be
a challenge for you as a brilliant
philosopher
in many ways and i and i look up to you
so much and the work that you do
uh you have such a cheerful demeanor
such a wonderful attitude
i do believe uh er er that that you are
the way a thinking intellectual should
be you should consider
all sides you should do so with grace
and composure and you do it so
wonderfully well
now with that buttering up i'm going to
ask you the tough questions what do you
say about the allegations made on 60
minutes no
i'm just kidding um okay the first
question i ask all my guests is what
would you put in your ethical will
in hebrew we have a concept known as or
ethical will
it's the amount of it's a type of will
not materialistic but wisdom-based
what would you put in a wisdom will for
future generations
of your ideological if not biological
heirs
maybe it's what you were just talking
about
about uh taking the militancy out of a
discussion like this
and there's there's militant theists as
well yes
and these are the great questions right
that we've been discussing
and they're fun and they're uh
engaging and uh they're worth talking
about
and so i've often felt a kinship with
people on the opposite side
of the debate if you will or maybe on
the
more on the materialistic uh
naturalistic atheistic side agnostic
side
right uh because they share that common
that common
interest in the deep questions so i
would say my ethical
will would be a grant of interest in the
big questions
very nice yeah i always say debate but
do it with love
second question relates to arthur c
clarke i'm the co-director of the arthur
c clark center for human imagination at
uc san diego
and you may remember from the movie 2001
a space odyssey these primates come upon
this enormous monolith
and they don't know what to do with it
they hit it with a bone or two and then
later on you see it you know on the moon
surface etc
and it's basically a time capsule and
it's meant to last a billion years
and it was similar to the time capsule
made by that great atheist and his
his wife who was a guest on my show uh
carl sagan and
sagan and anne yeah and durian i was a
wonderful person
and they made the voyager golden disc
which is lasting billions of years as
nasa told them
i want to ask you what would you put on
a billion-year time capsule
that would encapsulate everything that
humanity stands for
or that we've learned and we've grown
from or maybe a warning
what would you put on such a piece of
material
first of all anyone who found such a
piece of material as
in 2001 space odyssey would be making a
design inference
based on the information containing
their
that's right but couldn't resist
uh well i put the magna carta
i put the ten commandments i put the
i probably put the the u.s constitution
um i put the principia
um uh and i probably put a lot of the
great works of 20th century science
so yeah there's also there's also a
passage from the hebrew bible that i
love uh psalm 111
and there's a there's a uh a part of it
that's
inscribed on the cavendish laboratory
door in cambridge the old covenant
was put there by james clark maxwell it
says
great are the works of the lord sought
out by all who take pleasure therein
and further on in that passage there is
uh
the line he has caused his wonders to be
remembered
and uh that's something i often inscribe
in books as i'm writing
because i think part of what we're
seeing is is the handiwork of god and
i think it's great to bear witness to
that
yeah absolutely yes i often put on you
know the heavens declare
the handiwork of god um well that's very
good actually i
asked the same question to andrewian and
she quoted from
the the prophet mika and she said or
micah
she said um act justly
and love mercy and i said and you're
forgetting one last line of that yeah
walk humbly with your vlog before yeah
beautiful
and she said yeah i know but it's still
great
i have a lot of respect for her she's a
lovely human being okay the last
question stephen we've gone forwards in
time with your ethical
not your material will now we're going
to go backwards in time
not a billion years backwards but uh
actually just back to when you were a 20
year old
lad uh as you talk about a little bit of
your upbringing in the book
and um and some of the conflicts you had
it's a very deeply personal book i think
as well
it's it's exquisitely scholastic and
scholarly and i'm just so
pleased i could play a infinitesimal
role in this book and i hope it's the
beginning of a mutual
uh series of dialogues about maybe
judaism and christianity
and science should do more of this yeah
it'd be a lot of fun
a lot of fun the last question allows
you to go backwards in time as
sir arthur c clarke said the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture
a little way past them into the
impossible
and that's the name of this podcast uh
so when i ask you what
baffled you about life as a 20 year old
30 year old perhaps just starting off
your career your life your family
whatever
what baffled you but makes sense today
because you
stephen had this rare gift of courage to
go into the impossible
well i'd go back a little bit further
than 20 to 14.
i had an existential crisis as a young
teenager
i broke my leg in a skiing accident i
had an
overly active mind nothing was going
right at the time at
school or in my family and i started to
have these questions that would
percolate into my consciousness i don't
know where they came from they were
completely unwelcome but questions about
the the one that formulated itself most
clearly was what's it going to matter in
a hundred years
i could think of everything that i had
done in a day
and it all seemed rather pointless and
it was furthermore going to be repeated
by virtually the same routine in the
next day and while i was
reading or while i was kind of a lesson
from
my skiing accident i had a full leg cast
kind of confined to bed and i was
reading a book about the history of
baseball i was
hugely fanatical about baseball at the
time
but after i read the stories of each of
these great heroes
of yesteryear from the sport i found
that they all had the same kind of
trajectory they
came up through the minor leagues they
were scouted they were full of promise
they made the big leagues uh they
accumulated records they won world
series
they won home run titles or
um batting championships then their
statistical output started to decline
they retired they enjoyed the rest of
their life with a celebrity that came
from being
a sports star but then eventually they
died and all that was left was these
records on a piece of paper
and i got to think what so that's it i
mean
the thing that i thought was the highest
thing a person could do be a
professional baseball player resulted in
kind of this empty feeling that i had at
reading these stories and then i started
to think well how is it different for
anything else you could accomplish in
life
and i got this sense of what what's it
going to matter in 100 years there must
be something that
that doesn't change that
that in time bothered me a great deal
this kind of constant
flux of of impression sense impressions
going by and there was nothing that
seemed stable or consistent
and i thought there must be something
that doesn't change that gives meaning
or coherence to everything that
constantly does
change and uh for me it was
uh i was 14 at the time and then i had
the existential crisis came and thinking
that
probably there was something wrong with
me for asking these questions
i began to worry that maybe i was insane
and i just put me in a downward spiral
of
of uh fear about thoughts that
were questions that i couldn't answer
and it was later in college that
i encountered a lot of the same
questions and the existential
philosophers and
and i remember sharing with my
philosophy professor
oh i i told him about the experience
that i had as an adolescent and i
now realize i wasn't insane i was just a
philosopher and he said careful there's
a fine line between
philosophy and insanity but i think for
me the
the thing that that i uh found
personally was
a conviction that there was actually a
god and that there was an ultimate
purpose to human existence there's no
nothing can mean anything to a rock or
an atom or a planet but things
acquire meaning or meaning is conferred
by persons in relation to other persons
and if there is in fact a personal god
behind the physical universe then i
think this search for meaning that all
of us have as humans
as i say at the end of the book need not
end in vain and for me it didn't
uh stephen i want to thank you so much
for going into the impossible i wish you
wish you the success and blessing and
happiness that you
are so richly deserving them and i hope
we'll meet again for more of these
stimulating
stimulating impossible conversations and
i hope it won't take 14 billion years of
evolution and design for us to come
together again
fantastic these conversations are often
impossible because of that
underlying hostility that we talked
about between different groups but i
think
uh we've made it possible this morning
thanks to a great question so
thanks for having me on really festival
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
foreign